good morning believe nation today's
message is keep this simple over to you
Sean honestly speaking I think I keep it
very simple as I've always kept it very
simple so I wake up in the morning and
I'm like can I get that one shot right
like I thought 20 years ago that I hope
I get that shot right and I keep telling
my wife you know I find it strange I'm
44 now and I wear makeup to work but I
find out that you know I've kept it so
simple I'm not bothered about you know
what I'm going to do through the world
of cinema for the world no I just want
to make a film in which I am able to
tell you a good story so I think that
way keeping it simple and keeping it
real like everyone says a lot of people
in America keep it simple keep it real I
think that really is the mantra nothing
is too complicated I just want to do
like so there is important message for
entrepreneurs in that when you're
learning something new just keep it
simple if you make it too complicated
you're likely gonna fail and you're
likely gonna get frustrated you're
likely gonna give up and I think too
many entrepreneurs are trying to do too
many things they're not focused you know
you try to get on social media and so
you're spending hours in social media
and you don't know what you're doing and
you're trying to get on all the networks
all at once and as a result you're just
wasting time and time and time not
getting the results so it's really
helpful I find to have one main big goal
that you're shooting towards in my
mastermind groups here in Toronto what
we do is everybody has a year end goal
that they're shooting towards and every
month when we come for meetings we have
to say we're at for our year end goal
and it helps
keep your focus keep it simple
especially as an entrepreneur who has
limited time and limited resources you
know you don't have an unlimited team
working with you yet and so focus on the
things that you are amazing at that you
want to learn and get better at and that
will drive some significantly amazing
business results for you that's it keep
it simple we're gonna keep this video
simple remember done so the questions of
a today is how do you keep this simple
how do you keep its impact leave in the
comments below we'll join the discussion
thank you so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe and
we'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another